[Musik]
weißt du eigentlich wie toll ich dich
lieb hab so doll das ist die Wahrheit
und drückt
weißt du eigentlich wie toll ich dich
lieb hab einmal bis zum Mond und zurück
ich habe dich lieb das ist kribbelt in
den Zehen und das Kitzeln da am Bauch
will nie mehr gehen so lieb dass es fast
ein bisschen Trick immer wenn du lachst
ja dann lach ich einfach mit manchmal
bist du weg und dein Platz ist leer dann
wird in mir plötzlich alles schwer ich
werde traurig und will und die Sekunden
zählen jeder einzelne bis wir uns
endlich wieder sehen ich schenk dir
jeden Schatz alles was ich habe weil ich
Dich einfach noch mehr als alles mag
werde ich immer hier in meinem